good morning and and thank you that
Thomas Goetz and wired for allowing in
touch helped to be here today and to
share with you are dr. Roboto as its
said in the program and so I will be
co-presenting today with ulan Wong who
is our CEO I'm going to start off and
spend just a few minutes taking you
through the commercial journey that
we've been on it in touch health and
then ulan long here to my right via
robot will be virtually joining us for a
portion of our segment and really
sharing a little bit more about indeed
his vision for remote presence and where
we've come as a company and as a
technology so with that with that here
we go so really there's a real like
legacy of innovation at intouch health
spanning really back to before we were
founded the the founders of in touch it
had previously founded a surgical
robotics company and had embarked on
really developing and pioneering
surgical robotics and from there we have
since moved on to taking robotics in a
different direction in healthcare and
and really with it with the pursuit of
how can we use robotics to really enable
physicians to be virtually present
really be able to to provide their
expertise and consultations when they
can't be physically there in a hospital
setting and there's really two drivers
that have enabled in touch to
commercialize this technology and bring
it forward to where it is today one
really a convergence of different
enabling technologies technologies such
as remote remote therapies technologies
such as the iPhone and the iPad and
ubiquitous communication devices medical
informatics and and and then really how
that all plays together into an
demon of a true remote presence with
what what we've developed into our
flagship product RRP seven robot which
is shown there at the bottom of the
slide so the second driver that really
is enabled the successful
commercialization of a robot that can be
very enabling in a healthcare
environment is really the notion of the
ubiquity of bandwidth that's occurred
really over the last number of years as
well as the as well as really the the
cost of bandwidth going down and it's
fair to say that our technology if you
go back 10 or 15 years would really have
been a very nice project but but really
we believe would not have been
commercialized well as it is today and
so it's really the conversion of
convergence of these two things which is
enabled us to get to where we are and
really it's enabled us to get to the
front the real promise of of
telemedicine and remote presence which
is a reliable communication device that
enables a physician to be really in two
places at one time so on a spherical
examiner is one of many small community
hospitals who are partners in
barnes-jewish hospital and Washington
University Medical School's acute stroke
network we're one of the largest
hospitals from festus to Cape Girardeau
Missouri so we serve many very rural
counties we have a hundred beds we take
care of any emergency that comes to our
door of course however sometimes you
need that specialist and when that
specialist is needed doctors here used
to reach for the phone to contact
barnes-jewish hospital but now a new
tool is helping them bring that
expertise right to a patient's bedside
it's a robot that includes a camera
microphone and television screen to
provide instant video conferencing will
make a huge difference I believe in the
quality of life for patients what it
really does is kind of expands our
ability to provide care to centers
remotely so this is using tella medicine
technology which is a video two-way
video between the patient bedside and
the practitioner it's one of the latest
ways technology is bringing the expert
ease of barnes-jewish hospital and
washington university physicians to
patients outside the immediate st. louis
area it is one of the unique things here
that we have neurology neurosurgery
interventional neuroradiology all kind
of under one roof with all with
expertise and all available 24 hours a
day seven days a week it will allow us
to bring more expert care to the bedside
in a more timely manner and obviously
what stroke patients time is of the
essence doctors say when it comes to
stroke patients time is brain important
clot-busting medicines that can oh so
we've really come to a new place now
with remote presence when we're trying
to help solve two fairly significant
unmet needs in the healthcare system one
around telestroke the ability to get a
stroke specialists to the bedside very
quickly and secondly secondly around
tella ICU management and there's some
staggering statistics here around around
stroke and and just the the prevalence
of stroke in our country and also around
tell I see you that have really driven
the use of our technology in these high
acuity clinical use cases and so today
ten years on from our founding in 2002
we've gotten to a point where we're now
deployed in over 650 hospitals across
the world mostly in the US we've got
about 70 telemedicine networks that have
been created using our technology using
our robot place that into outlying
hospitals enabling specialists to again
provide their care and expertise via the
robot to to hospitals and patients in
need and now we're actually a close to
six thousand clinical consult are being
done a month on our robots and indeed
we're saving lives every day or helping
to save lives every day through the use
of this technology
so what are some of the challenges
because you know we've gotten this far
over the last 10 years but certainly
there's there's more room to go and and
this is the Triple Aim in healthcare
which is really how do you deliver
better care high quality care at a lower
cost this is something that you know
politicians and and administrators and
and everyone is really focused on doing
and it's and it's not easy to do and
there certainly are still many
structural barriers and difficulties to
achieve the Triple Aim in healthcare
there are also technology and adoption
barriers and I share this slide and this
is actually you may recognize Thomas
gets up there interviewing Vinod Khosla
back in August and and but note had a
fairly provocative statement talking
about healthcare being like witchcraft
and based on tradition and the fact that
healthcare really must be more data
centric or data driven with wellness as
really a key driver and that eighty
percent of healthcare going forward
might be or doctors might be replaceable
by machines now in touch has has quite a
different view than mr. Khosla on that
and while we certainly believe in in big
data and the ability to to have data
support the the diagnosis and treatment
of patients we think there's a lot more
to it and so we've got a vision at in
touch for where healthcare can go as
enabled by data where where physicians
are not necessarily going to be replaced
by data but data can be very
complimentary to to to their ability to
deliver care high quality care at a
lower cost so what have we found is some
of the barriers at in touch because
certainly there are there are adoption
barriers to use and as you saw the RP
seven robot up there at barnes-jewish
hospital one of the things that we found
is of every ten doctors that are using
our system our robot actually about four
of them really love it they love using a
joystick and driving it around and they
actually are into that another three or
four are sort of indifferent to the
experience and then two or three say you
know I will never touch that I like the
nurse to push me to the side of the bed
and and then I'll deliver the care that
way so we've had to address those
barriers certainly as we've started
thinking about new enabling technologies
and we're about to share with
rp-vita here and you and Wong is going
to share a little bit more about it but
really what it comes down to is is is
this question which is you know what is
the future of healthcare and does
anybody know what this what this
represents on the screen who knows what
that is Prometheus it's the it's the
health pod from Prometheus right so and
a rather grotesque scene where where a
cesarean section is being delivered
through an autonomous robot that's
certainly not what we believe the future
of healthcare is well it's an
interesting and provocative scene ulan i
think is going to share with you a
little bit more about the vision of
where we see rp-vita and this is really
the grand unveiling of our PV de on the
world stage to wired and the wired
health conference we did unveil this
platform back in July at a smaller users
group in Santa Barbara but i'll let you
and share a little bit more about the
vision going from here great thank you
Charlie and it's a it's a pleasure to do
with you today and thank you for
allowing me to be here remotely present
I actually have my company work visas
starting a couple out this year which is
why I wasn't able to make it there in
person although I saw the program it
looks very very exciting I you know when
you have investors and you have board
meetings I'm back to kind of Charlie's
comments and starting with this point
out foot texture again for a second you
know it challenges we have in healthcare
are quite significant
and they're based on these trend lines
which are really just they're just
inevitable we have an aging population
we have a growing population we have the
same number of people going into
healthcare that that happened doing so
in decades and we have a continued such
specialization of Medicine which is
actually making it very very difficult
for us to be able to provide
high-quality care so
dan with gas everybody's online this is
why are dueling so I'll take over and I
think really what what you and speaking
to as he as we get more bandwidth I said
bandwidth with increasing I you know I
guess it's really we're talking about
how do we how do we narrow that gap and
where we're in touch has come with call
it remote presence one point 0 is really
the the enabling of access through
technology and bandwidth where we where
we want to go with with health care 2
point 0 is really how can devices like
rp-vita here really enable a
coordination of care true coordination
of care which is a combination of of
course technology but also people people
in process and really that's the key
it's how do we bring together
technologies that can be enabling that
can really be used and embraced by
physicians and caregivers and have those
technologies be tools and so what are
Pete what ulan was going to explain is
really that rp-vita has come to a new
place with the way that it was created
in concert with our partner irobot to
really be an autonomous robot this robot
actually can can map its environment so
map a hospital environment and actually
as opposed to having a physician have to
drive the robot with a joystick which is
our previous technology dr can now point
on a screen literally on an ipad and
tell the robot to go from point A to
point B and it will proceed that way
without having to be driven back dowon's
back so I tried my best to fill in for
you alright so this is the challenge of
a demo in a hotel where you are on the
guest network and I was literally
connected for half an hour ahead of time
and I did not have any drop off so we
thought that the guest network was fine
and then someone probably downloaded a
whole series of YouTube's right as i
started talking and and that's what
happened so that I mean the one thing
which which we can't you know you we
require is bandwidth so back to what I
was saying the issue is with all of the
trend lines going how do you get the
high quality care
to the right place at the right time to
do the right thing and the bottom line
is if you can do that you can actually
reduce costs and provide high quality
care at the same time which is actually
what everybody is looking for solutions
to so this is why we developed this
remote presence concept what's happening
right now I'm actually in my office in
Santa Barbara California and I'm logged
into you and i'm actually going over the
public internet when we started this 10
years ago we didn't know whether or not
the public internet was going to have
sufficient bandwidth low enough latency
high enough quality in order to support
this kind of application before this it
was these ISDN lines which are point to
point and they were very very costly as
well but with the proliferation of the
internet now this kind of connection is
possible so I'm coming up I've got a
broadband lined up to the public
Internet I've got my cloud service which
is constantly monitoring the best way to
make this connection possible and then
I'm dropping down into where you're at
and then what's always the soda straw if
you will is the last half mile and so I
you know so that's where we're on the on
the on the guest network of the hotel
there which has you know as many users
as is required as as go on to it at any
given time now in a hospital environment
we would actually secure a certain
amount of bandwidth off their pipe such
that there always is sufficient
bandwidth to do this so a little bit
about rp-vita and and and and this
remote presence the idea is that we want
to enable the clinician to be able to be
present somewhere else from anywhere to
anywhere and operate and work as if they
were standing there in person and so
that's the objective it's a little bit
like you know the movie Avatar but
obviously for clinical applications
where the physician is as enabled as
possible to move and interact in the
environment as if
they were there Charlie mentioned that
previous to this rp-vita we've had a
system called rp7 I think he showed a
quick video of it which actually uses a
joystick in order to in order for the
clinician to move around and we've had
good adoption as Charlie mentioned we're
in over 600 hospitals but it's really it
captures the visionaries mindset but as
we're making progress in terms of market
adoption we needed to really drive
easier ease of use and so this is what
our PV is all about we actually
partnered with iRobot in order to build
the platform you see in front of you
today and what rp-vita has it it which
is quite unique it's the first time it's
happened in the world is it has
environmental awareness because of a
combination of a very sophisticated
sensor suite and a and software vida
knows its surrounding and because of
that it can actually automatically move
around amongst people throughout a
hospital in order to get from one place
to another and do things so now what
this environment with this environment
environmental awareness will allow us to
do is first it will allow us to get the
ease-of-use even easier it's a little
bit the analogous I liked analogy I like
to use is as we transition from mp3
players to the ipod everybody got on to
the digital music bandwagon because it
was so easy to use the objective here is
that the clinician just holding an ipad
taps on the ipad where they want to go
and it goes there and i can't i can't
show that to hear because I'm on the
other side but that is actually what
we're capable of doing now so that's the
ease of use the next step is actually
Charlie showed a video which was
actually bringing expertise from a large
center to a lot to a smaller center out
in a rural location
we're telemedicine has started
telemedicine is started by providing
higher level expertise from a larger
center to a smaller centres and this is
like this is where applications like
stroke like I see you etc makes sense
but I think that this concept of
telemedicine and remote presence has
much further to go where we can go in
effect if you can move to the next ok
you're on the right slide already it so
so this concept of enabling access is
where the field is that but I think it's
very possible to take us another step
forward to where we're coordinating care
in the year 2000 the IH IH I published a
report to err is human it showed that
the eighth leading cause of death is
actually medical error 100,000 lives a
year lost because of medical error and
it's really all about the coordination
of care as patients as staffs from the
day shift handoff to the night shift as
patients move from the outpatient center
to the inpatient center as patients are
transported from one location to another
the care across that continuum is not
well documented and the flow-through is
in exact and so we think that by the
uses of telemedicine and platforms like
this the rp-vita we can actually drive
to the next level of telemedicine to
where we're not only enabling access to
where care is needed but also we're able
to retune how care is delivered so that
it is more coordinated it is resulting
in higher quality and lower costs so
those are the main points I wanted to
make Charlie and so maybe I can turn it
back to you and I'd like to thank you
all again for the opportunity to be here
and I'm going to go to my board meeting
thank you one all right all right thanks
okay bye so in wrapping up here we're
going to share just a little video
vignette to spark a little bit of
some concepts and ideas on where the
future can be through our pvt but I did
want to just reiterate what Thomas get
said yesterday about using this forum to
really spark ideas and thoughts we hope
we provoked some some thoughts and ideas
around the use of telemedicine
technology be I would love to hear some
thoughts that you all have individually
out in the hallway as you start thinking
about applying this to practice in your
various industries but this has been a
very much an exciting journey for in
touch to get to this point and with that
we're going to share a video and we'll
move on to the next presentation thank
you at precisely 725 am a routine yet
remarkable event transpires at Metro
hospital as rp-vita a revolutionary
remote presence robot automatically
undocks capable of being sent to any
location by simply touching screen this
morning it travels independently to the
critical care unit where it will access
clinical data and choreograph care by a
multidisciplinary team each year nearly
100,000 lives are lost in US hospitals
most of which are due to lack love and
errors in communication Metro hospital
is helping eliminate preventable deaths
by focusing on patients and using
rp-vita to coordinate the delivery of
multidisciplinary team based care today
rp-vita starts by alerting the first
patient care team members which include
a nurse respiratory therapist and case
manager who attend in person while a
critical care doctor surgeon and
pharmacist join in remotely upon
arriving rp-vita displays patient data
for the remote team members and a
radiologist is invited to participate by
tapping its touch screen the
consultation concludes by detailing
daily patient goals and the nurse
accompanies rp-vita to the next patients
where the process is repeated once
rounds are completed rp-vita
automatically returns to its charging
station and docks
for the next coordinated team care
rounds or to perform any of a growing
number of clinical uses that are making
remote presence routine